en fait 3 milliard en plus pour nous les
collectivités territoriales c'est le zig
zag entraîneur philippe son discours de
politique générale et président la
république finalement s'est rendu compte
que c'était pas forcément le plus
opportun de faire une reculade donc il
l'a imposée mais il l'a imposé en 10 ans
collectivités territoriales mon choix
politique c'est vous qui allez le
supporter est passé en quelques jours de
10 à 13 milliards
quand sur le dernier quinquennat c'était
11 milliards parlons concrètement
concrètement une ville comme alfortville
nous avons fait 7 millions d'euros
d'économies dans le précédent
quinquennat on nous demande de continuer
moi j'ai un président la république qui
dit à la conférence de territoire je
n'étais pas il faut que vous fassiez des
efforts mais nous les maires nous avons
fait les efforts en termes d'émissions
firme révise moi cela fait deux ans de
consécutif où la masse salariale a
diminué de 2%
le paradoxe c'est qu'au vous êtes un
maire qui n'augmente pas les impôts
locaux ce que je fais depuis cinq ans
quand vous êtes un maire qui investit
près de 20 millions d'euros par an
depuis quatre ans qu'est ce qui se passe
bien vous avez les magistrats de la cour
des comptes qui vient faire son audit
qui vous tape sur les doigts en disant
un vous devriez augmenter les impôts
parce que ça vous donnera des recettes 2
vous investissez trop sur l'avenir pour
notre ville notre ville endettée les
habitants du cardinal